INTERVIEWER: Hello.
I'm Bill Lattanzi, and today
is April 27, 2012.
We are speaking with
J. Meejin Yoon.
She's an architect, designer,
and artist, the founder of MY
Studio, and co-founder of
Howeler and Yoon Architecture.
At MIT, Miss Yoon is associate
professor and director of the
undergraduate program
in architecture.
Welcome, Meejin Yoon.
YOON: Thank you.
INTERVIEWER: The MIT community
probably best knows your work
from the FAST Festival last
year as part of the 150
celebration, when you, it's fair
to say, dressed the MIT
campus with art.
Can you describe how that came
about and how you felt about
how it went?
YOON: Well, I think the FAST
Festival was an amazing
opportunity to bring together
different disciplines around
the arts at MIT.
The notion of having a Festival
for Art, Science, and
Technology I thought
was fantastic.
And Todd Machover brought me on
board to curate a series of
installations by students and
faculty all around campus.
And the idea was to curate it
in such a way that over the
course of a semester these
installations would pop up in
an unexpected spaces, first in
kind of interior niches and
circulatory areas, to create a
kind of sense of, well, what
is that, and transform the space
for an instance, and
then culminate in a series of
more I would say strategically
placed installations that
highlighted the
river axis at MIT.
So the initial interior projects
from the winter
months happened along the
Infinite Corridor axis.
And then the spring/summer
installations happened along
the Memorial Drive, right
along the river.
And it was a way to kind of
gesture to Boston and
Cambridge, like this is also
our front door, even though
the kind of internal community
really uses the Infinite
Corridor kind of circulation.
INTERVIEWER: It was a way of
expanding out people's sense
of the campus?
YOON: Yes.
It was a way of sort of turning
MIT inside out for a
brief, brief moment
to the public.
INTERVIEWER: And I think that
this wasn't just faculty work.
This was student work as well?
YOON: Yes, absolutely.
It was probably 50 percent
student work, maybe more than
50 percent student work and
50 percent faculty work.
And we really did try to
encourage collaborations
between theaters students and
architecture students and
Media Lab students for
those projects.
INTERVIEWER: Can you give me
an example of one of the
student or interactive projects
that were developed?
YOON: Sure.
There was a project right off
the Infinite Corridor that was
done by a PhD computation
student, two PhD computation
students who collaborated with
some of the Media Lab
electronics engineers.
And they created a kind of
interactive wall that was all
magnetized.
And so the poles on the magnets
created different
kinetic movement on
the installation.
Yes.
INTERVIEWER: So as I walked
by, it would move?
YOON: It wasn't responding to
necessarily your movement, but
you were moving the installation
and it was
triggering different lights
as you did that.
INTERVIEWER: So here's
a question.
I often hear artists talk about,
this will make me think
what's happening here?
This will make me think afresh
about my environment.
Can you say more about that?
Why is that a good thing?
What's your aim?
YOON: Well, okay.
So, you know, one of the student
installations, it was
called Dis(Course) 4.
They're Course 4 students.
And what they did was in one of
the four-story stairwells,
they hung a giant--
I can only describe it
as a chandelier.
But it was basically a modular
piece that was made out of
different units that could
basically aggregate in a way
that tapered in and then
back out again in
that four-story stairwell.
And what's interesting is we're
above or next to-- or
we, meaning architecture,
is next to mechanical
engineering.
And then there's another
department the
floor below, et cetera.
But when this installation
happened, people I think went
out of their way to actually
circulate on this stairwell as
opposed to going--
I know I did, because it was
such a beautiful installation.
And you would see people kind of
obliquely one floor below.
And it did kind of foster--
because it was so unfamiliar,
by basically defamiliarizing
one's environmental contacts,
it creates discussion and
questioning and asking, oh, who
is one floor below us in
mechanical engineering?
INTERVIEWER: That's great.
Partly I think on the basis of
the success of FAST-- it was
tremendously enjoyed by the
community and surveys said
that we should do more
of this at MIT--
the University just announced
a new program, CAST, or the
Center for Art, Science,
and Technology.
What's art doing in the mix
here at MIT anyway?
Aren't artists as far apart from
engineers as you can get?
YOON: I don't know.
I think if you look at the MIT
community, the artists here,
their work is inseparable from
science and technology.
And I do think there are certain
artists that might not
intersect with science
and technology.
But in the sense of the
quintessential Leonardo da
Vincis of the world, art,
science, and technology were
always intertwined, an
architect, an inventor, an
astronomer.
And I think that notion still
exists today in many people.
And I'm always amazed to find
engineers who are amazingly
creative or mathematicians who
are amazingly creative, and
then artists or architects who
are incredibly rigorous about
their design research.
So I don't think art, science,
and technology--
to me, they seem much more
seamless than I think maybe
the way our educational
kind of context--
not MIT's educational context,
but we grow up and think, oh,
you either go to a humanities
school or you go to a school
of science and technology.
You're either an artsy, literary
type of person or a
science/math person.
But especially when you're at
MIT, you find so many amazing
students in math and science
are brilliant musicians or
artists or designers.
So I think this place makes
you more aware of the
seamlessness between art,
science, and technology.
And if you talk to faculty,
I'm always amazed that the
lines are so crisscrossing
across the disciplines that
it's very hard.
You meet someone, and
they're like, oh, I
do structural origami.
And then you're like, huh, well,
that has so much to do
with structures in architecture
and design.
But they're looking
at it from math.
Or a biologist who's looking at
how certain components come
together, we would think of them
as components, but he's,
of course, thinking of them as
cellular aggregation, and how
similar we are thinking about
building module aggregation.
There's so much to learn
from each other.
But if we're kind of separated
into these
silos that never happen.
So what was amazing about FAST
was its ability to foreground
art, science, and technology.
I think MIT is a place where no
one questions the science
and technology.
But this is a place with
amazing, creative arts and
humanities.
And the opportunity to really
bring that to the forefront
for the 150th celebration was,
I think, a great, great
opportunity for those of us in
those fields, but also, I
think, MIT became more aware
of the kind of potential in
the arts as it relates to the
Institute in general.
INTERVIEWER: Showing the
community to itself or a side
of itself it wasn't aware of?
YOON: Yes, absolutely.
I mean, the number of people
that FAST Festival drew from
the general Cambridge/Boston
community, I think it was a
way of making the campus
more accessible
to a general public.
In every installation, there
was research and technology
involved from digital
fabrication to rethinking
modular aggregation to new
materials through energy
production with the solar
rockers by Sheila Kennedy.
I think people became aware
that, oh, there is science and
technology, but it can be
beautiful and change our
environment and be pleasurable
and be playful as well.
INTERVIEWER: That's great.
There's a quote we
found that--
what's been called, there's a
kind of chain reaction that
happens between the
arts, science, and
technology at MIT.
Is this the kind of thing
you're talking about?
YOON: Yes.
Absolutely.
I mean, I think the school, like
the Media Lab is probably
one of the let's say buildings
or envelopes that
has the most variables.
There are artists there because
the Art, Culture,
Technology program
is based there.
There are designers and
architects in terms of
students and faculty
in the Media Lab.
But there are also scientists,
physicists,
engineers, et cetera.
And I think you can sense, in
the amazing production that
place generates, just
a creative energy.
And I think that creative energy
comes from the synergy
of multiple disciplines.
I think you need to bump up
against people from other
disciplines in order to
re-question not only how you
think about your own discipline,
but, oh, in fact,
aren't we much more connected
than we think in our desire to
change the world but through
different avenues.
INTERVIEWER: I was looking at
one of your talks and you
talked about art, science, and
technology being something
when you put them together you
get a whole that's more than
just plus signs between them.
YOON: Yes.
Absolutely.
INTERVIEWER: Yes.
Can you say a little more?
I mean, you have been, but--
YOON: Yes.
I mean, I think that when there
is synergy between three
things you get much more than
the sum of its parts.
I think that the much more is
you get something unexpected.
I think typically you can
guess what this kind of
research might lead to,
what this kind of
research might lead to.
But recently one of our alums,
Skylar Tibbits, who's one of
the TED fellows this year, is
collaborating with a biologist.
And they're working on--
basically, the biologist is
working on an area researching
how cells know what
can combine and
what can not combine.
Sorry.
That's my very low, low
biology-speak of that idea.
And Skylar is also looking at
it by just using mechanical
energy, so like shaking a tube
of different modules, they
aggregate in precise ways
because the modules are
designed so they only go
together one way and not
another way.
And that he learned through
biology, through this
collaboration.
And I think you put two people
in two different disciplines
together and you ask them, maybe
you should have coffee
or a discussion and
collaborate.
You can't force collaboration.
But I think you never know
what's going to come out of
that crash of ideas.
INTERVIEWER: That's great.
And there's a lot of that going
on at MIT, it seems.
It's encouraging.
I wanted to back up
for a minute.
We'll come back to MIT.
I want to back up for a minute
and talk about what brought
you to this point.
But go all the way back and,
without telling your whole
life story, I can supply from
my research that you
were born in Seoul?
YOON: Yes.
I was born in Seoul, Korea.
But I grew up mostly in
the United States.
I had a very traditional
architectural education.
I have a bachelor of
architecture from Cornell, and
then a master of architecture
and urban design from Harvard.
But when I graduated, I did
a Fulbright in Korea.
And I wanted to work on very
big- scale urban projects,
because in Korea at the time,
cities for 300,000 people were
being built over night.
And I thought, well, we need
designers to think about that.
After a year of working at an
urban research institute, I
thought that is an important
cause, but
that's not what I love.
I love cities, but I want to
do it hands-on, not through
policy and not through sketches
that will take time
to turn into a master plan
for traffic engineers
to resolve, et cetera.
I wanted a more immediate way
of changing the urban
environment.
And I thought you could change
urban environment through
small-scale interventions.
So I started my own kind of
practice doing installation
work in public space.
One of the maybe most known
projects is a project called
White Noise/White Light for
the Athens 2004 Olympics.
But that doesn't explain
how I got to MIT.
So I came to MIT in 2001.
And I came out of an invitation
to apply for a
junior faculty position
in architecture.
And what's amazing is I think
MIT changed my life.
Not only that it gave me a job,
but it changed the course
of the way I thought about
architecture and the city.
INTERVIEWER: You've been
here 10 years now.
So how did MIT--
YOON: I've been here 10-- so
when I came in 2001, as I
mentioned, I had a very
traditional architectural and
urban design education, one
that was devoid of any
technology in terms of the
way I was trained.
I was not exposed to so many
things about design and
technology in terms of
computer-aided design or
manufacturing, et cetera.
So when I came here in 2001,
because MIT has that word
technology in it, I
was very nervous.
And so my first semester of
teaching, I also signed up to
be a student.
So I took a course at the Media
Lab called, How To Make
Almost Anything, which is taught
by Neil Gershenfeld
because I thought, I'm so
technophobic, I should take a
course that makes me less
fearful of technology.
So during that first semester
I was teaching a studio, and
then simultaneously
I was a student.
And MIT has this great benefit
where they pay your tuition if
you take a course, but you have
to get a B or above to
get reimbursed for
that course.
So it was like the only course I
actually ever cared about my
grade, because I was worried
that I wouldn't get it
reimbursed.
But I got an A. And I learned
a lot through that class,
because it was a crash course
in computer-aided design,
manufacturing, basic
electronics, microcontrollers,
prototyping.
And the final project of that
class, for my final assignment
I created something called
the Defensible Dress.
And later iterations of that
dress were exhibited at the LA
MOCA and the National
Museum in Tokyo.
But the idea behind the dress
was I want to defend my
personal space from people that
crowd it in urban contexts.
And so when anyone entered
a space zone
that I could preset--
24 inches was my comfort zone.
I think culturally it's
different if you're in Spain
versus Tokyo.
So the idea was you could
program your distance, your
personal space distance.
If anyone violated that, this
dress lifted like a porcupine
with these spikes, and
kept people away.
INTERVIEWER: Did you ever
wear it in public?
YOON: I did wear it in public.
And I had students wear
it in public.
And it was shown on a mannequin
in the museums.
INTERVIEWER: What was that
experience like, just briefly,
and for the students,
especially.
YOON: I think people were
like, what the?
They were kind of
surprised by it.
But at the same time I think it
resonated with everybody at
the same time.
It's a crazy project, but
everyone has had in public
space a feeling of kind of
personal space encroachment.
And that was the project that
you can deal with kind of big-
scale issues through a small,
personal scale intervention.
And that's what led to the
White Noise/White Light
project for the Athens
Olympics.
That's what has led to a lot
of my work that deals with
interactive design and
alternative energy and
transforming a public space.
INTERVIEWER: So I'm going to
digress one more step.
And then we'll come back
to how MIT changed you.
So in teaching, how do students
respond to this?
I'm thinking of-- and I may have
a wrong stereotype of the
engineer, where everything has
to be quantified and logical
and explained.
This idea of the Defensible
Dress, a big abstract idea and
a concrete object and the effect
of it is hard to put
into words.
Art is often beyond words.
How do you translate that to
students and how do they
respond to it?
Do you get resistance?
YOON: I feel like at MIT you
don't get resistance.
I mean, I think the first
resistance would be a person
that would ask, well, why would
you want to do that?
But I think MIT--
I've never found anyone that
asks me, why would
you want to do that?
It's, huh, that's really
strange, but that's kind of
interesting.
So how are you going
to do that?
And I think that's the nature of
Neil's course, how to make
almost anything, not what
should we make?
Why should we make it?
So I think in a way Neil's
course coupled with the kind
of just general fearlessness
of MIT--
like there is the attitude of
not why, but why not, and a
lot of support.
So I could take a class
as a faculty member.
I could learn about things that
I was sort of afraid to
admit that I didn't know much
about when I started here.
And it did change the trajectory
of my work.
And it could only have
happened here.
If I had taken a teaching
position at any other school,
my work would not be the
work it is today.
INTERVIEWER: You've lost
your technophobia.
Are you a technophile now?
YOON: Well, I would say I am
still wary of technology.
But I think that wariness is
a super-healthy aspect
of the work, too.
But I am fearless because
I now know
people who are fearless.
You know, once we were
doing a project.
It was a sound installation,
used capacity sensing.
And it produced sound, so I was
like, well, we should get
a small MP3 player.
And the engineer I was working
with was like, why would we
buy an MP3 player?
I'm going to just make
it from scratch.
And that kind of attitude,
that MIT has people who
actually still make things,
is pretty rare.
We don't just talk
about things.
We don't just philosophize
We make things.
We test things.
And everything we make hopefully
impacts the world
from the artist side to the
engineers that invent devices
that help people.
INTERVIEWER: MIT, learn
to be fearless.
That's a pretty good slogan.
YOON: Yes.
Yes.
INTERVIEWER: So now I want to
flip it around and ask the
other side of the question
that I think is actually
harder to answer, which is,
you've been here a decade.
How have you influenced MIT?
YOON: I don't know if
one person like me
can influence MIT.
I mean, I think that over the
decade I have seen change in
my department.
In the Department of
Architecture there is more
openness to interdisciplinary
collaborations, more openness
to projects that typically
would be seen on the very
periphery of architectural
design, because it's dealing
with either urban issues
or landscape issues or
interactive design issues
or mobility issues.
And I don't know if I'm
responsible for that or just
over the last decade all the
departments have become more
interdisciplinary, because the
problems now that exist in the
world are such that no one
discipline can solve them.
It requires the collaboration
of a planner and an
environmental scientist and a
climatologist, or a geologist
and an electrical engineer
and an artist, maybe.
INTERVIEWER: So as head of the
undergraduate program here,
does that influence where you
feel architecture education
should go and how you're
planning the program for the
next 5, 10, 15, 20 years?
YOON: Yes.
I mean, I think that the
undergrads are the best asset
here at MIT.
They're incredibly bright and
energetic and unencumbered yet
by the rules of society and the
rules of the profession.
So they are fearless.
And for me, the important thing
about an undergraduate
program in architecture should
be that we train students such
that if they want to go on and
get a master of architecture,
they have a great foundation
to do so.
But we don't create a program
that railroads them into only
getting an architecture graduate
degree, that the
education really focuses on
design thinking in a broader
sense, so that they can go
on to doing anything from
management problem solving
to industrial design to
architecture.
And historically, we have had
something like 30 percent, 40
percent go on into
other fields.
So it's, I think, different
from some undergraduate
programs where like 90 percent
of the students go into that
area for their Master's
degree.
So it makes it a challenging
program to develop, because
you want to make sure the
students have enough exposure
to the kinds of course
curriculum that would prepare
them for a master
of architecture.
But you want to also make sure
that they're understanding
architecture in the broadest
sense, that it is constructing
the environment as
opposed to like
building a kind of building.
And I think we try hard to do
that by requiring courses in
both art culture and technology
and building
technology.
Our students have to take both
so that they understand that
architecture really does
sit between art and
science/technology.
It's like right smack
in the middle there.
And I think the best
architects have a
strong grasp of both.
INTERVIEWER: And even, as you
say, it's part of a liberal
arts education.
You can do anything from it.
It strikes me as you're talking
that as we go along
into the future, society
gets more
technological, more visual.
And the difference between
design- thinking and thinking,
it seems to me, is getting
less and less.
And design is very useful.
If you have design principles,
it applies to
great number of fields.
Is that true, do you think ?
YOON: Yes.
I mean, I think for me design-
thinking, it starts with how
to analyze a problem and a
context and break that down.
And it requires thinking
strategically and iteratively
about multiple ways of attacking
that problem through
the production of something.
So I think that's where we are
designers and architects,
because our goal is actually
to make something that is
inhabitable or spatially
experienceable that changes
the context.
INTERVIEWER: Tell me a story,
one of your favorite stories
of your undergrads, project
or success stories.
Anything that stands
out to you.
YOON: We've had some amazing,
amazing undergrads.
There is a graduate of our
program named Lisa Smith who
was one of my favorite
students.
And I met her initially because
she was put on--
I don't remember what
MIT calls it.
But she had some disciplinary
hearing or something.
So my first day of studio, she's
like, Professor Yoon,
I'm sorry I have to leave 30
minutes early because I have a
disciplinary hearing about
something I did.
And I was like, oh
my goodness.
She's going to be
a troublemaker.
It turns out she had created a
survey using MIT letterhead.
But the survey was kind
of a joke survey.
So it was kind of very clever
and funny, but because it had
the MIT logo on it,
she got into some
disciplinary problems.
But she created this megaphone
project where she got into
trouble again, because as a
public art piece on the
streets, she was screaming from
a megaphone about certain
political issues.
And to me she represents the
perfect spirit of MIT
undergrads who want to change
the world and are using--
and yes, they get into
some trouble.
But I think the reason they're
getting into that trouble is
because they're really trying to
make other people aware of
certain conditions and finding
ways through that awareness to
then make positive change.
INTERVIEWER: So was the
megaphone project her final
project or did you work with her
on developing things maybe
so she could do these things
without getting arrested or
did you encourage her
to get arrested?
YOON: Well, you know, I didn't
encourage her to get arrested.
But I supported her in finding
ways to get her projects done.
And she graduated from here and
then she went to the Art
Institute of Chicago,
where she got a
master's in design objects.
And now she's a very successful
designer, but she
designs polemical objects.
INTERVIEWER: What's a
polemical object?
YOON: She designed these mats,
but they have a message to
them, a political message to
them that isn't just text, but
the perverseness of the thing.
Or a lamp that's designed so
minimally that it's a line.
So it doesn't look
like a lamp.
It actually just changes your
reading of space and
perspective.
INTERVIEWER: So we've touched
on this a little, but in
looking forward just
architecture schools in
general over the next decades,
what's the biggest challenge?
YOON: I think the biggest
challenge is going to be in
dealing with environmental
issues.
Buildings, of course, take
up the most energy.
If you look at charts about what
consumes the most energy
in the United States, it's not
cars and it's not trains and
it's not planes.
It's actually buildings.
So I think that's going to be
the biggest concern for the
next generation, how to design
in such a way that our
buildings are smart and
intelligent, reduce energy
use, while still creating
amazing environments for us to
do things in, creating
collaborative environments,
because more of those kinds of
spaces will be necessary.
INTERVIEWER: But on the other
hand, I've read that urban
centers in places like New
York in some ways are the
greenest places of all because
there's so much density.
YOON: Yes, because
of the density.
Yes.
But in the United States, I
don't think we'll ever have a
condition where there'll
be 12 Manhattans.
So I do think architects need
to think about how to build
sustainably at all
kinds of scales.
Like at the suburban scale,
because the car is part of the
American dream and until we
change the American dream,
we're going to have suburbs.
So in a suburban context, what
can we do to create the
maximum amount of energy
efficiency?
INTERVIEWER: In the graduate
level architecture design
studio course you've been
teaching for the last decade,
you ask your students to quote,
"think design through
systems."
YOON: Where did you here that?
INTERVIEWER: It's been
given to me.
Referring to the challenge
issued by architecture critic,
Reyner Banham.
So can you tell us a little more
about that and how that
works in the context of MIT?
YOON: Yes.
I think it's very important to
think through systems, through
designing systems, as opposed
to designing a one-off
exquisite design object.
INTERVIEWER: I've heard the
masterpiece is dead.
YOON: Well, it's not--
I mean, I love masterpieces
still.
But the masterpiece only
addresses one percent of
architecture, if that.
Maybe you 0.1 percent of one
percent of architecture are
the masterpieces, especially
in the United States.
But if you can design a system,
whether that system is
a way of design, or if you can
design through organizing
structural, mechanical, and
programmatic systems in a way
that work smartly and still
produce amazing spaces, I
think that's the key, as
opposed to all the top
architects producing one-offs.
That is not going to help change
the environment that 99
percent of the world, or 99
percent of the United States
lives in, works in, plays in.
INTERVIEWER: What's a
successful example?
What's the most stand-out
example of a place or a system
that's doing it right anywhere
in the world that we
can look to as a--
YOON: There are some great
historical examples, that I
would say range from Hadrian's
Villa, where--
INTERVIEWER: In ancient Rome.
YOON: Yes.
I mean, I think where space
is organized so
that it deals with--
in terms of the baths,
the hot, the cold.
And there's an organization
to that and an integration
between the architecture and the
technology of the time and
the program in a really
integrated way.
INTERVIEWER: By program we mean
that that's the place you
go to have a bath.
YOON: Yes.
Yes.
And to me, that is an integrated
system, so
integrated that you can't take
one thing out without it all
just kind of falling apart.
Maybe a more recent example
would be like the Centre
Pompidou in Paris.
But there, they codify
the system.
So on the outside, you
see all the colors.
And that's because they're
showing which ones are
plumbing pipes and which ones
are mechanical ducts, and
intake, outflow, et cetera.
And that's a building that
literally turns inside out in
order to make the public
kind of aware of the
systems of a building.
I think many architects, like
Foster's building in Hong
Kong, the Hong Kong Shanghai
Bank, is a masterful example
of how structural systems work
together in an integrated way.
INTERVIEWER: How about MIT?
Does MIT work well as a
system of buildings?
YOON: I think MIT is a kind
of campus of ad-hoc-ness.
INTERVIEWER: It's a kludge.
YOON: It's not a system.
It's the aftermath of
piecemealing and making things
work ad hoc, bit by bit.
And I think as we move forward,
every time I'm
outside on a street and I see
them digging up my street,
because I live in downtown
Boston, they're digging it up,
all the asphalt, to
run something.
Who knows what it is?
Bios.
And then like three weeks later
they're digging it up
and then somebody's running
maybe a gas line under there.
And to me, that's what I mean
by it's not thought through
like a system.
It's always being dug up and
something added in, as opposed
to thinking through what it
means to have infrastructure
in an urban context embedded
with buildings.
I think there is a
different way to
think about that problem.
INTERVIEWER: It seems like we're
coming to grips with
change in architecture
as well.
I was hearing a story the other
day about a brand new
building that they spent years
and millions of dollars--
or no.
It was an old building that
they retrofitted so that
everybody could have an
ethernet connection.
By the time they finished,
they didn't need them.
YOON: Yes.
Technology leaps.
And architecture is slow.
So there are many buildings--
like I think even the Stata
Center here at MIT, between
when they started designing it
and when it was built was
many, many, many years.
And buildings take
a long time.
They take a long time to design,
12 to 18 months.
And then they take a
long time to build,
another 18 to 24 months.
By the time you add that all
up together from the minute
you started to draw your first
line to when people are moving
in, we've had four years of
technological revolution.
So architecture will always
remain kind of-- because it's
still built by humans,
still physical.
So it will always be bridging
kind of low and high
technologies.
I think that's also what makes
architecture really amazing.
I think of a wall as a
form of technology.
It separates me from
whoever else.
And the way you design the wall,
if you undulate the wall
it has different acoustic
properties.
If you splay the wall, it has
different optical qualities.
So I still think the most basic
forms of architecture
technology are incredibly
manipulatable.
And so I think the challenge
of an architect now is we
still have to design amazing
walls, but now we have to
integrate them with
infrastructural systems and
technologies that are
constantly changing.
And it used to be people told
me that, oh, buildings are
really only built for a lifespan
of like 30 years.
But I think most people stay
in buildings much longer.
The building I live in in Boston
was built in 1890.
And so we have to think that our
buildings are not like 30
years we're going to
just tear them down
and build them again.
But how can the building adapt
to transformation?
INTERVIEWER: I'm always struck
by, this year especially at
the Design School, how
buildings, as you say, they're
both technology, but they're
ideas in space and time.
And now this idea seems to
be flexibility, change,
adaptability.
YOON: Yes.
Every architecture project,
every good architecture
project, is based on an idea.
It's based on a concept.
And I think we saw in the '60s
and '70s, especially in Japan
after the war, a lot of research
into thinking about
adaptability.
It was the Metabolist Movement
at the time.
But adaptability,
transformation, a way to
re-imagine the future of Tokyo,
big visions, and a lot
of great heroic buildings that
researched these ideas.
I think in the US we had
that moment too in the
'60s and the '70s.
And I think in Boston there
are many great--
I would call them masterpieces,
but maybe some
people in Boston would call
them abominations--
buildings that were really based
on an idea and testing
those ideas.
INTERVIEWER: You're not talking
about Government
Center, are you?
YOON: I'm talking about the
range from Exeter Library to
the Government Center to
Rudolph's public service
building on Cambridge Street.
Yes.
INTERVIEWER: Wow.
Defend Government
Center for me.
Change my mind.
YOON: Well, I think the diagram
is interesting to--
the first move to create such
a giant public plaza.
I'm not saying it was done
right or that it works.
But there was a clarity about
the idea that there would be a
huge public plaza, huge,
based on Siena.
They didn't quite get the
Siena part, but--
and that the government building
would be kind of
transparent to the public.
The mayor's office would be
where it is, with the glass
windows, that there'd be a giant
courtyard in the middle
that brought daylight
internally, that the ground
level would have all the public
administration for
taxes and whatever, for people
to go pay their bills or
whatever they do down
on the lower level.
So it was meant to be an
incredibly porous building.
It didn't work that way, because
I think after it was
built they closed off most of
the entries and so it turned a
circulation that was supposed
to be about porosity for the
public into kind of a labyrinth
because of security issues.
And the world changed between
the optimism of that
public-ness to the realities
of security today.
INTERVIEWER: I think it's been
most successful for me when
they put up those big screens
when the Red Sox were in the
World Series or something like
that and it does becomes this
wonderfully warm, festive
civic place.
YOON: Yes.
I think in the United States,
you can't have public space
without programming, without
something happening in that
space, because--
and especially in Boston-- we
don't necessarily have the
culture or the climate to
support the public just
hanging out in a plaza like
Boston City Hall's.
INTERVIEWER: So what keeps
coming up in your work really
is civic engagement.
It's really using art and
architecture to promote civic
engagement.
How has that mission evolved
in your field,
and where is it going?
Are we going to see
more and more--
YOON: Well, I mean, I think
there are all kinds of
architectures.
But I think architecture
is most
present in a public context.
So it used to be that the
Forum in Rome, like that
architecture made civic space.
It helped define civic space.
It helped foster civic space.
For me, I'm very interested now,
because we have less a
notion of civic space in the
United States than maybe a
more neutral word like
public space.
But I'm very interested in how
architecture and public space
work together, how public
architectures can help change
the mission of an institute.
We just finished the new
headquarters for the Boston
Society of Architects
in our practice.
And the BSA moved from Broad
Street to Atlantic Wharf.
And with that move, they are
leasing a space which is about
15,000 square feet which
has almost all of
that on a second four.
And the ground floor is about
1,000 square feet.
But it's got window front, but
it's on the second floor.
So that project for us was all
about how can we make a second
floor space, because it's
a gallery, seem
as public as possible?
And it's a Chapter 91 space, so
it needs to be public and
it needs to be accessible--
INTERVIEWER: Chapter 91?
YOON: I don't actually know.
INTERVIEWER: Just if you get
money from the State you have
to have it accessible
to the public.
YOON: Yes.
And it has to be programmed
as public space.
So it is an architecture
gallery.
And our idea was that we would
create a move that would try
to make that second floor space
seem part of street,
which was very challenging.
So what we did was we gave up
all the perimeter of that
space to the public programming,
to the galleries.
We pushed all the staff offices
and conference rooms
back off the glass so that
you could, from the
ground floor, look up.
And we created this green soffit
in the ceiling, so that
ceiling acted kind of as a
facade, because you could see
it from the street.
And then that ceiling like
scooped down to make a grand
stair that people
kind of walk up.
And it's painted bright green
so you can't miss it.
And the idea is you scoop
up the public.
They end up on the second floor
space and they see the
architecture exhibits in the
context of the city.
So they can look right out the
window and see what design is
doing is trying to make an
impact and change in the
physical world we inhabit.
INTERVIEWER: You're both a
working architect and a
working artist and teacher.
Do your students get
involved in your
architectural projects?
YOON: Yes.
We do take summer interns.
And we hire many graduates
from the department.
And then another way students
get involved is
through UROP projects.
So some of the design research
work I do, I hire
undergraduates to help with.
INTERVIEWER: UROP is?
YOON: Undergraduate Research
Opportunity.
It's a really special program
MIT has, where MIT, the
Institute, supports faculty to
hire undergraduate research
students for their projects.
So I think typically faculty
would tend to hire graduate
students over undergraduate
students, simply because they
have more experience or they're
directly involved in
their labs already.
But MIT's program is really
trying to encourage undergrads
and faculty to have a closer
relationship and give
undergrads an experience they
wouldn't have otherwise.
So MIT actually pays the
undergrads directly to work on
faculty research projects.
So one project that I used UROP
students on was a project
called Unsolicited Small
Projects for the Big Dig.
And it was a book project where
we did a lot of research
on the Big Dig and the kind of
infrastructural overhaul of
that project.
And then we made speculative
conjectures on a series of
projects that are very, very
hypothetical that could've
happened or may one day happen
to make the Greenway more a
vital public space.
Because even though it is a
public space and it is a park
and it is increasingly well
used, there was not much
intention or--
maybe intention is not
the right word.
But there was not much
specificity in thinking about
what could happen on those
parcels, those new parks, now
that we had this huge
way of connecting
the city back together.
It's unprecedented as an urban
project in the United States.
And very little, I think, was
thought about what you could
do beyond just making it
a really nice park.
INTERVIEWER: So what's
an example?
What could you do?
YOON: Well, like last year a
young architecture firm called
Studio Luz produced a giant
hammock on one of the parcels,
a hammock that like 20 people
could hang out on
simultaneously.
Some new interventions, like
the carousel, I think, has
been successful.
But I'm thinking more like why
isn't there like a parcel
that's just 100 dirigibles?
It is such a unique kind
of urban space.
And I don't think the
activities on it are
particularly wonder-filled
or unique.
It's public, but it doesn't
gather people let's say
together, other than that water
fountain, which is super
successful.
INTERVIEWER: So we need a
Christo to come put the gates
in and get us--
YOON: Absolutely.
I think once a year they should
have an artist do
something that ties
all the parcels
along the line together.
And then other times there
could be different
environmental transformations.
I think the Harbor Island
Pavilion has
been a great success.
So I think over the years after
it opened there have
been more experiments on how
to make the Greenway civic
space as well as a park space.
INTERVIEWER: Any reaction from
your unsolicited suggestions?
YOON: Oh, I think people were
very nervous about it, because
some of the proposals were
really crazy, because I am
frustrated that there
are still so
many lanes of traffic.
And even though it's supposed
to be a linear park, because
you have to cross a road every
time if you're trying to jog,
it's not a really linear
experience.
So I proposed in one of the
projects a jogger's E-ZPass.
So you would put a little
E-ZPass on your ankle
and you would jog.
And as you jogged, it would
literally stop all the lights
so that it privileged the
pedestrian, as opposed to our
current environment which always
privileges the car.
So as the pedestrian jogs, not
only do all the walk/don't
walk signs work in their favor,
but a landscape of
trees follows you, so you never
have to see the cars.
So they run with you,
these trees.
INTERVIEWER: I love that.
Is it like a people-mover
with trees on it?
How does it quite work?
YOON: I didn't figure--
it was just very speculative.
But that book led to actually,
surprisingly, an invitation
for me to join a working group
that is now thinking about
public art on the Greenway,
public art and programming on
the Greenway.
So I think it led to
the right thing.
INTERVIEWER: I've done a few of
these interviews now, and
it seems there is a common theme
at MIT of striking out a
huge vision, never mind whether
it can actually be
done or not, but put
a flag out there.
This is where we want to go.
And then figure the reality
to get there.
And you might not get
where you're going,
but you'll get somewhere.
YOON: Yes.
I think that's right.
I think that somehow MIT
encourages the big, big ideas,
the big visions.
But we're not clowns.
We're professors doing
real research.
And so it's an interesting way
of speculating on a big vision
and what are possible
instruments that lead to that
big vision.
Sometimes it's almost like
a marketing campaign.
It's like putting the idea out
there in order to generate
enough activity and
discussion.
And through that,
you might create
policy change, et cetera.
In other cases, it's like
speculate on that big vision,
but what are the intermediary
steps to
get to that big vision.
And I think that's the luxury
of being a professor at MIT.
I think in practice I'm always
thinking of our projects last
anywhere from three months
to three years.
We don't really have projects
that last 30
years in our practice.
And you're always under
tight deadline.
And you have to work
with realities.
And you're doing absolutely the
best under really tight
time constraints.
The amazing thing about the
academic environment of MIT is
they really encourage long- term
thinking and short- term
projects that get to that
long- term thinking.
So you can say, I
have this idea.
I don't think we're there to be
able to implement this in
the next even 5 to 10 years,
but maybe 20 years
out, 30 years out.
And we need to start thinking
about this and talking about
this now to get there.
That's the luxury.
And that's why I can't leave
academia, even though I also
love practice.
INTERVIEWER: How do you work
out that balance between--
you're everywhere all the time?
YOON: Yes.
It is an impossible--
I think there is no such
thing as balance.
INTERVIEWER: How do your
students respond, MIT students
in particular, to this laying
out of the big idea.
Are they thrown by that?
Do they love it?
YOON: I think it depends.
I think like for the graduate
students, I
think they love it.
I think the undergraduate
students are
actually more skeptical.
Like, no, you need to
teach me how to
really build real buildings.
So I think we have both.
I mean, I think that's what
makes MIT so unique.
INTERVIEWER: So how do you
introduce them to the joy of
imagination, free thinking,
letting go of the practical
for a moment before you
come back to it?
YOON: Through either abstract
exercises, so abstract that
they don't really know
they're designing.
One of my favorite exercises
is I ask
them to make a drawing.
But in order for them to make a
drawing, they cannot draw on
that drawing.
What they have to do is design
a set of rules, such that
their classmates each by
contributing one hour of their
labor on that piece of paper
can produce the drawing.
And the rules can't
be too elaborate.
So I make them stick to
one page of rules.
And it produces the most
extraordinary drawings.
And this is what I mean by like
thinking through systems
or designing a system.
I want the students to design
the system for the drawing.
They can invent the tool.
I let them invent the tool
if they want, and
then a set of rules.
And then one student says, draw
this specific pattern
until you hit the edge
and then go this--
like so it creates
a chain pattern.
Another student asked them to
put the paper on a wall and
with their hand try to find--
because our walls are full of
holes because of all the push
pins for printing up--
and copy every location of every
hole, and then the next
student to connect
all the dots.
And it produces beautiful
drawings, because they're not
so willful about some
metaphoric, poetic intent.
But they are precise and they
are based on a logic that the
student constructs.
And what they learn from that
project, I hope, is that
design is not about pure
individual authorship anymore.
Design requires the
participation of many.
But you, as the designer, need
to make sure that there is
clarity about how that design
will be executed.
That's one lesson from
that exercise.
And I think students every
time are just profoundly
impressed by how beautiful
the drawings are.
From just an aesthetic point of
view, the drawings always
end up much more beautiful than
they could have done if
they sat with a blank
piece of paper and
tried to draw something.
INTERVIEWER: That's great.
That's really good.
Where do you go from there?
What's your next exercise?
YOON: Well, I also do an
exercise where sometimes I ask
students to take a historic
building, like a '60s and '70s
building, and we blow up the
photographs really large.
And I ask them to just sort of
Photoshop, like re-imagine it.
And so it's not again working
from a blank piece of paper.
But how would you have
done it differently?
So one thing they learn is they
have to figure out why
the original architect
made those decisions.
Then they come to really
appreciate those decisions.
Sometimes they're like,
I can't do anything.
It's really good just
the way it is.
But I say, okay.
It was designed as a library.
Now you have to re-imagine
it as an energy farm.
And then they kind of loosen
up and they go wild
and they have fun.
INTERVIEWER: Is there
something in this
re-contextualization or
defamiliarizing that is
involved with your artwork?
White Noise/White Light or the
Philadelphia piece that drew
people to the water?
YOON: Yes.
No.
I think there is something I
think that's really important
in design education that you
need to, for students, break
down what they think
architecture is.
Many students when they come
into an architecture program
they say, oh, I've been around
buildings all my life.
I know exactly what
a building is.
Teach me how to draw plans and
I'll go on my merry way and
design buildings.
And the first thing is, well,
what is a building?
What are the things that create
or not create social
interaction?
How do you deal with
the ground plane?
How does something meet
How do you think
about barriers?
From the labyrinth to the
continuity, how can you
rethink circulation?
And so we try to abstract those
exercises so students
really understand space and
not buildings, because our
goal is to design space, and
that produces buildings.
A building is just a volume that
separates you from your
larger environment.
So what is an envelope?
How can envelopes perform from
an energy point of view but
also from a social
point of view.
Certain buildings, like we were
saying City Hall, it was
meant to be porous, but it
absolutely doesn't work.
How can you decide a
porous building?
INTERVIEWER: So we were talking
about architecture
moving forward, maybe always,
as a design of space, rather
than a design of buildings.
So let's speculate a little
about the future.
If you had a magic wand and
could redesign the campus,
take your Photoshop, your real
world Photoshop, and open it
up and make it more of a
designed, functioning place,
what would you do?
YOON: I'd do many things.
But one of the first schemes I
think I would do, just from
having been here so long and
understanding the way people
think and work--
and it would make a
terrible campus.
And it would be vetoed by all
architects and planners.
But I think the MIT community
would love
to be in one building.
So it would be one mega-building
that would clear
across the whole campus.
There would be lots of
perforations in it for
courtyards, so there
would be lots of
day-lighting, et cetera.
But it would allow you to get
from any department to any
department without
going outside.
And it would have lots of--
I don't know what you
would call it--
non-defined spaces in terms of
who owns it, so that you could
have impromptu research
generated by multiple groups
simultaneously.
It would be incredibly
transparent.
It would be all glass on the
interior, so that you could
see what was going on.
And it would be no more
than two floors, maybe
three floors max.
Which is not a great use of the
land, but what it means is
everyone would walk.
So no one would need to
take an elevator and
go into a dark cube.
One of the stories I heard once
from a friend of mine who
used to work at Bell Labs, and
he said it was an amazing
place to work and that so much
impromptu discussion and
innovation really occurred
through serendipity, because
people would run into each other
on the stairs, because
everyone used the stairs
in Bell Labs.
And all the great discussions
happened on the landings.
I thought that was fantastic.
So if I could redesign MIT,
it would be one giant
mega-building, a lot of
transparency and day-lighting,
with millions of courtyards.
But everything would be two or
three floors so that every one
would run into each
other on landings.
And it would be designed in such
a way that no one would
take one route.
Maybe it would be designed
so that always the routes
changed, or you couldn't always
take the same route,
because I think you get
into a habit at MIT.
You go down this corridor, this
corridor, this corridor,
this corridor.
You run into the same people.
But if the routes were always
changing in this labyrinth of
the future MIT, you'd run into
all kinds of people, pass all
kinds of things, and
be like, huh, wow.
Someone is creating a robot
that climbs that wall.
The gecko, that's kind of
interesting, because I'm
researching a 3M product that
is about sticky surfaces.
Maybe I should collaborate
with him or talk to him.
INTERVIEWER: That's very cool.
I was at Pixar once years
and years ago,
shortly after they began.
And I don't know what they're
like now, but at that time
they were in giant Quonset
huts, kind of
airplane hangar buildings.
It was the same deal.
And people rode around on
scooters, little hand scooters.
So that could be
part of it too.
You could have a take it and
leave it scooter perhaps.
YOON: That sounds good.
INTERVIEWER: It's a little
bit like that now.
I mean, MIT, it's embryonic and
not fully realized, but it
does seem to be that there's
a lot of meeting in the
hallways, meeting
in corridors.
YOON: Yes.
Yes.
But I feel like the spaces are
not the kind of spaces you
want to just linger in
forever and ever.
It is just the result of
corridors and hallways and
bridges and connections, as
opposed to being really
thought of as network.
INTERVIEWER: This comes back
to the FAST Festival, where
the pictures I saw-- it was
not here, but the Green
Building and that area, it did
seem to make it into a
networked community public space
in a way that, to me at
least, it just feels--
YOON: Isn't now.
INTERVIEWER: Yes.
It's not now.
Was that a deliberate aim that
the students had, or you had?
YOON: Well, you know, yes.
I mean, I think that, for
me, for the windscreen
installation I did on the Green
Building, for me that
place on the campus is
strange, because
first it's a tower.
But also because it's so
windy nobody enjoys
being in that space.
And even though the other side
of the Green Building runs
parallel to the extension of the
Infinite Corridor, because
the weather's always so
bad nobody uses it.
So I do think the goal was to
actually take spaces that are
underutilized on MIT's
campus and then
make them more utilized.
Or to use some aspect
of them to--
INTERVIEWER: So what are
you working on now?
What's the next big
art project or
architecture project?
YOON: We're doing a couple
interesting projects.
We were asked recently to do a
permanent installation art
piece as part of the General
Service Administration's
Percent for Art and Architecture
program.
So it's fun, because I get to
change hats and be the artist
in an architecture project.
But this is for the San Ysidro
border crossing, which is the
largest land border crossing
in the world.
And so they're expanding it.
It'll be 34 lanes of traffic.
They process 3,000 people an
hour in the pedestrian lane.
INTERVIEWER: California-Mexico?
YOON: Yes.
Yes.
INTERVIEWER: 3,000
people an hour?
YOON: That doesn't seem
right, does it?
It must be 3,000--
3,000 people a day doesn't
sound right either.
INTERVIEWER: 3,000 an hour.
Could be.
YOON: Yes.
And we're doing a solar-powered
canopy in the
city of Phoenix on Roosevelt
Row, was another project.
On the architectural front,
we're looking at redeveloping
Avery and Hayward Street here
in Boston, the streetscape.
What else are we doing?
We have a lot of projects.
Oh, we're doing the
plaza in front of
Harvard Science Center.
We're working with Stoss, which
is a landscape firm, to
rethink that.
And we're specifically focusing
on the media aspects,
lighting and media aspects
of that project.
INTERVIEWER: So people say you
should never go into business
with your friends.
You're in business with
your husband.
How does that work out?
YOON: We're still friends.
So my husband was one
year ahead of me in
undergrad at Cornell.
So he was an upperclassman
by one year.
And when we graduated, he went
to New York and then I went to
Boston for my Master's, or
Cambridge for my Master's.
And he continued on his track.
So he worked for eight years at
KPF, big firm in New York.
And then three years for Diller
Scofidio, which is the
boutique firm that the ICA
project here in Boston.
And I did my thing.
I did my public space
installations.
I did small- scale residential
projects.
And in--
I don't remember--
2006 we said we'd join forces.
And we were like, what kind of
practice are we going to have?
Because he has big--
he did towers at KPF.
He worked on the tallest
buildings in the world.
And Diller Scofidio, he worked
on really important cultural
venues, like the Institute
of Contemporary
Art and Lincoln Center.
And me, I had done an
installation at the
Guggenheim, and for the Athens
Olympics, and much smaller-
scale interventions.
A dress.
What kind of firm are
we going to have?
So we've combined our forces
and it's been an adventure.
I mean, I think we both really
rely on each other's opinion.
We really respect it.
But we have very different
approaches to design, so it
works out well.
INTERVIEWER: In a way, you're
kind of embodying this future
for the field that you're
talking about, combining
designing space and art
influences with a more
traditional building approach.
YOON: Yes.
Yes.
INTERVIEWER: So you represent
the future.
So I'll come back in another
20 years and
see where you are.
YOON: Hopefully, we'll still
be in operation.
INTERVIEWER: So why
do you teach?
You don't have to.
YOON: Yes.
I don't know.
I can't not teach.
I mean, I feel always inspired
by teaching.
Like I'm on sabbatical this
semester, so I've been really
focusing on the work in the
studio, in the office.
And I miss teaching.
Like I have this itch to be
around young, energetic people
who are unencumbered by the
realities of the world.
And they encourage me to always
think with open eyes,
with an open mind
about a problem.
And because I'm professing a
certain way I think that
design should be thought about,
as I profess to them, I
can't be a hypocrite.
So it keeps our office, I think,
and studio having the
highest ambitions in terms of
design and not giving in and
kind of selling out to the
realities of the world.
INTERVIEWER: They keep
you on your toes.
YOON: They keep me on my toes.
Yes.
INTERVIEWER: Well,
that's great.
I think that's all I have.
Thank you so much.
YOON: Thank you.